abone ol
[Müzik]
e
herkese merhaba Çok keyifli bir toplantı
Ben Can kayacılar temelde bir yolum 2002
yılında Abant İzzet Baysal Üniversitesi
biyoloji bölümü ne girdim on Senem
biyoloji ve Daha sonrasında da İslam
Üniversitesi deneysel Tıp araştırma
yazıyor sinir bilim bölümünde geçti bir
10 yılında özel sektörde Aslında
birçoğunuzun bildiği bazı
gıdaları tasarlamakta ve gıdalar
yaygınlaştırmak da geçti temelde hem
akademisyen hem de yarı şeyim neydi Özel
sektör şeyim Şimdi ben sizi iki şeye
yüksek lisans çalışmalarına götürmek
istiyorum sinir bilim bölümünde e uzun
yıllar boyunca alzaymır parkinson
depresyon işte Bağımlılık gibi birçok
hayvan modelleriyle çalıştım ve bu
hayvan modellerini inim modellerinde en
çok satan denilen Aslında bizim
bitkilerde gördüğümüz Elmadağ elmaya
rengini veren ya da muza kokusunu veren
ya da ne bileyim bir marula
o sevdiğimiz kokusunu veren şey
antioksidan moleküllerle çalıştı ve
antioksidan moleküllerin Aslında
canlılardaki moleküler mekanizmaları
Yani biz antioksidanları tükettiğimiz
zaman bu En çok sana bize ne gibi
etkiler yapıyor yani bizi mesela
kaslarımızı daha güçlü kılıyor bizi
hastalıklardan bu koruyor ya da tedavi
edici özellikleri var Bunları çalıştım
ve Bu çalışmalar sekiz yıl boyunca sürdü
yani Biz hayvanlara Öncelikle
antioksidandır verip daha sonra
hayvanları hasta edip ya da önce
hayvanları hasta edip daha sonra
antioksidan moleküller vermeye başladık
Ve bu süreçte Aslında antioksidan
bileşenlerin hastalıkların tedavilerinde
kullanılamayacağını Yani biz eğer
alzaymır oluyorsak eğer kan bu Eğer de
diyabet sake bunlarda
kullanılamayacağını ama an çoksa
moleküllerin özellikle hastalıklardan
bizi koru Ya bileceğini gördük ve
buradan yola çıkarak aslında bütün
Türkiye toplumunun sağlığı ile alakalı
bazı çalışmalara giriştik yani Buna
aslında
beslenmeye bağlı hastalıkların
engellenmesi anlamını taşıyan bazı
çalışmalar yaptık mesela Bu salonda
bulunan her dört kişiden 1'ini Biz
maalesef kalp-damar hastalıklarından
kaybedeceğiz bir bir o kadarını
kanserden bir o kadarını diyabetten bir
o kadarını obeziteden kaybedeceğiz
Önümüzdeki on yıl içerisinde Türkiye az
rhymer görülme sıklığında dünyada bir
numara olacak ve bunun gibi daha bizim
inanılmaz hastalık büyüklerimiz var yani
buradaki salondaki herkesin tanıdığı bir
çok az birçok hastalığa sahip insan
vardır ve biz bu beslenmeye bağlı
hastalıkları Burada gördüğünüz gibi ve
giderek artan sayıda Aslında Türkiye
toplumu hastalığını your ve bu
hastalıkların temelinde de asla
tükettiğimiz gıdalar ve yaşam stilimiz
geliyor öncelikle
tükettiğimiz bu ve dağları tamamen şey
yapmak durumundayız zenginleştirmek
durumundayız ki hastalıklardan
korunabilirim mesela beslenmeye bağlı
hastalıklar da özellikle kalp-damar
hastalıkları Bir numarayı tutuyor yani
Biz aslında sağlıklı olmak için üç
basamağı yerine getirmeliyiz biz
birincisi sağlıklı beslenmeliyiz düzenli
spor yapmalıyız ve güçlü sosyal
ilişkilerimiz olmalı Eğer bu üç basamak
olmazsa biz kendimizi sağlıklıyız
diyemeyiz Yani oturduğumuz yerden
Sağlıklı beslenmek aslında bizi sağlıklı
kılmıyor ya da sürekli spor yapıp Can
kurtlarla beslenmek bizi yine sağlıklı
yapmıyor ya da tamamen izole bir ortamda
yaşayıp hem sana hem Sağlıklı beslenmek
hem Spor yaparsak bu da yetmiyor bir
güçlü sosyal ilişkimizin olması
Fiat Panda mi bizi bu bizi bundan
ayrılırdı ve iki yıl boyunca Biz evlerde
durmak durumunda kaldık ve o nedenle
pandemi özellikle Türkiye'de
depresyon görülme sıklığı çok arttırdı
anksiyeteyi çok arttırdı Evet çok şükür
ki bu salon Artık pandemi siz Belki
benim çıktığım ilk kalabalık salonlardan
bir tanesi biz bunları Türkiye toplumu
olarak bazı şekillerde bazı gıdaların
zenginleştirilmesi ile aşabiliriz yani
Mesela biz bunları fonksiyonel gıda
ediyoruz antioksidanlar C zengin
proteince zengin multivitamin mineral ve
zengin koleje zengin aklınıza ne
geliyorsa ama zenginleştirilmiş gıdalar
yani karbonhidrat temelinde olmayan çok
farklı ve şekillerde zenginleştirmiş
gıdalar fonksiyonel gıda olarak bilmiyor
ve belki Bu salonda bir çoğunuz
görmüşsünüzdür 2019 yılında Ben
Türkiye'de fonksiyonel gıdaların
bilinirliğini artırmak için mor ekmek
diye bir şey yaptım ve bu mor ekmek abi
o zincir marketlerde Bütün Türkiye'deki
çok farklı illerde satılmaya başladı ve
mor ekmeği ek olarak mor baklavalar mor
gofretler mor şeyler markete gittiğimiz
zaman bunları görebilirsiniz Bunlar
mesela mor sebze meyve özleri içeren
aslında bir fonksiyonel gıda ydı şimdi
Gelecekte bizi çok farklı bir şey
senaryo bekliyor çünkü biz beslenmemiz
ya Türkiye toplumu Aslında malnütrisyon
yaşayan yani eksik beslenen bir toplum
ve bunu bunun giderilmesi gerekiyor
Öncelikle gelecekte geleceğin gıdalar
olarak iki basamak var Birincisi öğün
yerine geçecek olan gıdalar Yani biz
öğünleri mi Biz gıda larımızı artık
böyle daha kompakt daha
multivitamin mineral ve zengin Daha
besleyici forumlarda tüketeceğiz yani
kahvaltı larımızı öyle öyle yemeklerimiz
öyle sadece günde bir ürünü Normal
bildiğimiz klasik şekillerde beslenmeye
başla de bunun daha birçok etkisi var
Yani bu iklim krizin getirdiği bir şey
değil Hava değişimlerinin getirdiği bir
şey değil ülkeler arası Transport ların
bağlandığından dolayı kıtlığın daha
fazla yayıldığında dan değil vesaire
vesaire bunun gibi daha birçok şey söz
konusu ve burada Aslında öğün yerine
geçecek olan gıdaları bizim tasarlamanız
lazım bizim düşünmemiz ve bizim talep
etmemiz lazım firmalarda İkincisi de
Medikal gıdalar Biz Medikal gıdaları mm
30'lu yıllardan sonra konuşmaya
başlıyoruz Medikal gıdalar söyle biz
Eğer kanser hastalığına yakalandığı ysak
Biz kanser hastalığının tedavisine ek
olarak bizleri daha kolay atlata
bilmemiz ya da tedavi süreçlerini daha
kolaylaştırıcı gıdalar Bunlar ve ayrıca
mesela ağrı kesici özellikle gıdalarda
olabilir bu Medikal gıdalar bunun gibi
şeyleri yani fonksiyonel gıdaları
ülkemizde yaygınlaştırma İzbe ne
fonksiyonel gıda terimini ya Yazdığınız
zaman iyi 10 sene önce bunları
söylemiştim Kargo bu konusunu altı yıl
önce bahsetmiştim Şimdi size Aslında
Gelecekte bu gıdalar nasıl olacak
Türkiye Buradan nasıl katma değerli
ürünler çıkartacak ve Türkiye nasıl ile
ilgilenecek Biraz onun çözümlerinden
bahsetmek istiyorum Evet bunlar olmalı
ama nasıl yapmalıyız Bunun başında
tarıma düzeltmemiz lazım Türkiye
toprakları öyle söylendiği gibi çok
verimli Topraklar değil de yani Türkiye
topraklarının yüzde yetmiş beşi organik
materyal cinsinden 100'de 1'ine 100'de
iki organik materyal içeren Topraklar
önemli tüm toprakların Türkiye'deki
bulunan birçok toprağın temelde komposto
in eşi bizim organik atıklarımızı
Aslında çevrildi ye ve Aslında bizim
gıda larımızı farklı şekilde çöplerimizi
daha 4 ayrıştırırsınız bir basamakla
komposta zenginleştirir Malibu
yapacaklarımızın başında geliyor ve bunu
bir sosyal sorumluluk Projesi olarak
yapmalıyız Yani bunu mesela tanıdığınız
bazı ünlüler bu konuda bu ve toprağın
Aslında komposto zenginleştirilmesi
asıcı organik materyal C
zenginleştirmesi gerekiyor ikinci şey
büyüsü tüm ilanlar 1 stimülanlar
konusunu Eylül ayında daha daha net bir
şekilde duyacaksınız bir Osmanlı Aslında
bizim
proteinlerden ya da farklı Buyur
biyolojik moleküller den aldığımız bazı
örgütlerden oluşuyor Mesela bir aylık
özütü ya da bir protein parçası bir bir
öğütme oluyor ve bunlar gübre yerine
geçen gıda gübre yerine geçen
uygulamalardan bahsediyor şimdi tarıma
düzelttiği mi zaman yani komposto
zenginleştirmeye başladığımız zaman
seralar kurduğumuz zaman organik tarıma
geçtiğimiz zaman dikey tarıma
başladığımız zaman az önce Bütün
arkadaşların söylediği gibi tarımın
teknolojiyle gelişmeye başlar
geliştirdiğimiz zaman kalp ikinci bir
yap yapacağımız şey süperkritik
ekstraksiyon yöntemi Yani biz domateste
no kırmızılığını almalıyız ya da
karpuzlardan o kırmızı al bu süperkritik
ekstraksiyon projesini proses var Bunu
belki daha yeni duyuyorsunuz Biz bunu
yaygınlaştırmaya Türkiye'de bunun adını
daha fazla duyurmaya bu süperkritik
ekstraksiyon larla bütün işte yağ üretim
lerimizi ya da bütün ekstra
üretimlerimiz Bu forma çevirmeye
çalışıyor Bu nasıl bir form süperkritik
ekstraksiyon yüksek basınçta
karbondioksitin Aslında katı sıvı gaz
dan farklı bir formda
koyulan biyolojik materyal Ee difriz
etmesiyle ve bunu selektif olarak
saflaştırması ile meşhur yani Mesela
kahveden kafeinin nasıl ayırabiliriz ya
da domates ten kırmızılığını nasıl
alabiliriz ya da ne bileyim bir ayçiçeği
ayçiçeği Nino sarılığını yani Lite yine
yani gözlerimize iyi gelen o bileşeni
oradan nasıl alabilir sorusunun cevabı
hep süperkritik ekstraksiyon dan geçiyor
çünkü bu bunları yaptığımız zaman biz
tarım atıklarını değerlendirebiliriz Biz
aklımı ve tüm tıbbi ve Medikal
bitkilerden çok farklı sağlığımıza iyi
gelen molekülleri saflaştırma biliriz ve
bunları doğrudan Gıdalara katabiliriz
Böylece mesela Türkiye'nin sağlık
harcamalarını fonksiyonel gıdalar
kullanarak içimizde Muhtemelen Gıda
Mühendisleri var fonksiyonel gıdalar
kullanarak azaltabiliriz yani Biz
gelecekte obeziteye yakalanma ya biliriz
biz gelecekte diyabete yakalanma ya
biliriz alzaymırlı uğraşmaya biliriz
kanser hastalığı hastayı ulaşmaya
biliriz bunun gibi daha birçok şey tabi
bilişsel fonksiyonları mızı arttırırız
daha sağlıklı oluruz daha enerji
kalkarız vesaire depresyon engelleri
gibi gibi yani süperkritik
ekstraksiyonla yapamayacağımız şey yok
yani Adnan'ı bütün sebze meyve tıbbi
tıbbi Medikal bitkilerden yüksek katma
değerli ürün eldesi konusu yani Biz şu
an Mesela size Diyelim ki 8 bin dolar
gibi bir ortalama gelire sahip bunu 80
bin dolara Aslında süperkritik eksik bu
edebiliriz Çünkü biz bütün gıdalardan
bütün tarım ürünlerinde yüksek katma
değerli ürünler yapabiliriz bunların
Tesisleri Türkiye kurmaya başladık
ikincisi bitkisel proteinler gelecekte
bütün gıdaların hepsi bitkisel protein C
zenginleştirecek bazıları ve Selam bana
karşı bitkisel protein olur mu İşte
aslında biz Türk toplumu olarak beslenme
mizin yani protein ihtiyacınızın Yüzde
altmış beşinden fazlasının zaten bitkisi
bitkilerden karşılıyor nereden biliyor
musunuz bu salondaki herkes enerji
ihtiyacının yüzde ellisini ekmekten
karşılıyor Yani biz yoğun bir şekilde
ekmek tüketiyoruz ekmek TD 100 gram
ekmek T9 gram protein söz konusu Biz
bunu farklı yollarla 18 grama
çıkartırsak Aslında toplumun birçok
sağlık problemini çözmüş olacağız Çünkü
biz bu sefer daha dengeli besleyeceğiz
daha karbonhidrattan daha az
besleyeceğiz daha enerjik olacağız yani
bu protein bize sağlayabileceği etkileri
Gerçekten hayal edemiyorum ve bu
Türkiye'de bir dönüşümü başlatacak tabi
bitkisel proteinleri nereden elde
edebileceğiz mesela Türkiye'deki
ayçekirdeği fabrikaların dosyalarından
ya da mesela milyonlara Varan
domateslerin kabuklarını da ya da işte
ne bileyim aklınıza gelecek olan bütün
çer çöpten proteinler saflaştırılır
bilir ve bunlar Gıdalara katılabilir
beni İkinci büyük hayalim Bu ikinci
yapmaya çalıştığım şey bu yani Türkiye
bitse protein fabrikaları kurmak ve
bundan çıkan şeyleri gıdalarla
zenginleştirmek gibi şimdi ben ben
girişimci olarak Türkiye'de
2012 yılında Türkiye'nin ilk
teknogirişim birincisi ve Türkiye'de bir
Türkiye'nin ikna fiyat Yo teknoloji
şirketinde Grup 40 metrekareden 3100
metrekarelik ar-ge merkezine çevirmiş
bir insanım ve bütün TÜBİTAK KOSGEB işte
Teknoloji Sanayi Bakanlığı destekleri
almış bir insanım ben topluma örnek ol
Ben buradayım Benim bütün arkadaşlarım
yurt dışında hepsi gittiler hiçbiri
burada kalmadı Ve işte ne bileyim
irlanda'da isveçte Amerika'da ama ben
buradayım Çünkü bu toplumun bize
ihtiyacı var Bu toplumun hepimize
ihtiyacı var Çok teşekkür ederim ilginiz
için çok sağ ol